is everybody
we go
Oh
today
hey guys you just saw me in yamimash
fight to the death in the arena hope you
enjoyed that was just a ton of fun to
finally be able to hang out with the
guys that I've been doing videos with
for over a year now I've never met him
in person up until that point and it's
just so cool to be able to you know hang
out with this guy that I know so much
about and yet have never met and it was
just you know nothing changed like the
moment that we met you can see like our
meeting video over on Yami lasas channel
there's a link in the description and
there is another match where I fight him
again and he tries to fight a little
better than that time even though he
kind of cheated and threw himself at me
which I guess he didn't know was against
the rules and that's why I won but
there's more there I even fight
CaptainSparklez and there's a round of
that going over after this but I just
wanted to say you know I just got back
in from pax I literally walked in the
door started editing this video right
away and I am more motivated than ever
before to make cool videos for you guys
so sincerely thank you for this
opportunity thank you to everyone that I
met at pax I met more fans than I ever
had it was actually hard for me to walk
from one place to another before like
getting inundated with fans and I'm not
even saying that's a bad thing it was
such an honor that so many people came
up to me but anyway I don't have a lot
of time because I want to make sure that
this video doesn't get too long with the
fights that you're about to see so
there's more content on the way I even
recorded myself in the virtue sphere
which is like how a virtual reality
thing is a big rolling hamster ball that
is so cool and so weird to experience
but I got a POV inside of it and I had
yamimash taking film outside so it's
back that soon if not tomorrow but
either way
totally awesome thank you all so much
thank you John me Matthew I can now
officially call my friend so be sure to
check the description and check out
round 2 right now confident in my
victory I strut up to the podium here
you can see yamimash cowering in fear at
my display of manliness oh what other
perfection I am
the match will soon begin and already
yamimash is just quaking in fear
and here we go it begins as you can see
I flail in a seemingly random pattern
that just is intended to throw yamimash
off-balance and you can see it works
here in expert fashion look as I claim
my victory oh how great I am
yamimash is already meager confidence is
shaken as he looks around for an escape
route but he can't escape this arena
because it's a fight to the death so you
can see he tries his best to get his
beaver stance going as I have my
undulating Ocelot and it begins he gets
a cheap shot to the groin and I seem to
be off-balance but he is more so the
shame in his eyes is almost as obvious
as a stain on his trousers that's
British for pants but like James Bond
he's shaken but not stirred and he comes
back for more the poor sod that's
British for foolish guy I prepare my
crouching Tigger and he prepares his
hidden poo as we go at it again once
again my seemingly random flailing works
to my advantage and yamimash is almost
handily beaten until he's not certainly
yamimash must have cheated in this round
and therefore I tackle him with love yeh
CaptainSparklez also thought that he
wanted to mess with the likes of me and
no matter how charged up he was he was
never gonna beat me because I had my
good luck charm brought to me by a fan
we take our stances we ready our poises
we gird our loins as we begin right now
and I take an early shot he takes an
early spot and I am going to destroy him
with my once again seemingly random
flailing he tries to charge me cheaply
but it won't work I am too much man for
him to handle we ready ourselves for
round 2 as I get in the most bizarre
stance I've gotten into yet but just see
how effective it shall be
he hits high lunge
hits I lunge again well it's mostly him
lunging as he takes the most obvious
open spots that he could and hits me in
the groin Howie
that hurt yes you did hit me in the
cross you douche how dare you that hurt
a lot but I am NOT faced and I shall
claim my victory in my new stance the
overbearing bear come at me bro you're
going to die now your hey da oh yeah oh
and it's the ultimate roll and the judge
is calling it and I've won yes
die you bastard die you lovable awesome
bastard whom I respect greatly thank you
for the awesome fight captainsparklez
hold me on a great day so that was just
one of many awesome moments I had at PAX
I've met a bunch of youtubers I wish I
could have met more but I still hung out
with a bunch CaptainSparklez is awesome
Yami mess is awesome I got to hang out
with Wade and D live and Anton adieu I
can never remember his oh it's n2 and
that's it n2 and I hung out with him had
dinner with those guys they are
absolutely awesome sincerely thank you
guys so much and thank you to the fan
that gave me tiny box Tim hello how are
you doing everybody bye sincerely thank
you guys so much I can't wait to go to
more great convention in the future so
anyways I'm gonna end this on this note
and tiny box Tim is gonna say bye to you
guys too I'll always have him with me
and I may just use this guy as a base
for a plushie in the future so say bye
Tim bye everybody
bye bye